I worked together a lot of proposals and
tankers imagine we found each other
rather often and this is confusing
windows so those problems raise data
compression all right well thanks ms the
so thanks
so sometimes organizers do a lot of work
and other times they go along and do
less so I want to thank Petros for doing
all the work he did a lot of work and
put on put together a great meeting here
and this time I did relatively little so
thanks to Petros and I was talking with
Petros about six months ago I was
telling about these results we had on
using random matrix theory to
characterize implicit regularization and
the topic did you know these neural
networks and so does that spell by the
wayside and then he said oh could you
give a talk of course at this randomized
linear algebra meeting I said sure I
mean I could talk about bootstrapping
and regression or I could talk about the
low rank what do you want to so why
don't you talk about that crazy stuff
you're telling me about so this is what
I'll talk about today and so I have the
rather sort of grant out of a wide deep
learning works and what I'm gonna want
to do here and what does it even mean to
say why you know what's going to satisfy
you in terms of an answer to why so all
of this is work this is work with
Charles Martin who's here today and he
runs a boutique consulting shop in San
Francisco so relaf relative to academics
has a very practical guy but he has a
background in statistical mechanics and
quantum chemistry and and the way
theories formulated in quantum mechanics
and quantum chemistry is very practical
theory and so we want here is a very
practical theory and so in that sense I
think VC is not this because it's a
bunch of theorems that make certain
statements we want to we want a
practical theory for sort of why deep
learning works and so we're gonna try
and measure stuff and come up with a
theory and make certain predictions and
then see if the predictions have
anything interesting to say about
generalization gaps or going to any
other topics that people ask questions
about so randomized numerical linear
algebra
has a lot of connections we've been
talking about today but in a sense if
you're very careful about the theory and
where the theory fails the most
interesting connections are exactly
there you know when is the matrix not
well approximated by something low rank
or one of their other sort of structural
heterogeneities what does localization
on eigenvectors tell you one of the
things always struck me is randomized
linear algebra has never said it had
much to say about random matrix theory
and vice-versa so we're going to be
doing here is using random matrix theory
and in fact very sort of reasonably
sophisticated and novel variants of it
to ask questions about what's going on
and so I think if you think about
foundations of data of practical
theories is a good thing we want to
understand sort of why deep learning
works Oh scientific question we'll get
to that but also you know use it to some
end you know engineer better algorithms
and I came into this just a funny space
right because you have vici theory that
sort of as doesn't make qualitative
statements about how the methods perform
in practice use stochastic optimization
and everyone says oh and in convex case
it behaves such and such and they're
surprised when in some other neural
network that's not an SVM release scores
or something convex if it's totally
different as if these two should have
anything to say about each other and so
maybe you know there's a million knobs
and so you fiddle a lot and so can we
maybe get a better sense of how these
knobs interact maybe engineer better
learning at home so what a practical
theory so why does it work convex versus
not convex you know what does it mean
what does regularization you know it's
deep better or not fair talking about it
is deep better or not VC Theory versus
the testicle mechanics is a is something
in physics but it's also used
historically in neural networks
especially in the 80s and then the
mid-90s was sort of vanished and so now
it's slowly working its way back into
machine learning and and neural network
learning and so on so this will be
central to the lot we will talk about
and then very practical insights now
when is a network fully optimized when
do you stop training this is a very
practical question you just stop when
you get tired right so can you get a
better answer to that can you use labels
more parsimoniously you know you want
large batch or small batch questions so
these are the questions that it we're
gonna be talking about and so one of the
early motivation so I bumped into
charlet at a meeting a couple years ago
and we were got to talking about this
and he says well I mean these these
methods work because of such-and-such
you know how does it say that
such-and-such most of you would say you
know what what did you just say I mean
and and I said yeah yeah obviously
because I had happened to have a similar
background but I said but the questions
not you know that the question is
how do you make that obvious to everyone
else who parameterize in these arms and
thinks about Ottomans very differently
so this is the paper out of the NYU
group and they said well this is
evidence that the the model looks like a
spin glass and then they ran on to do
some other stuff and it's consistent
with that but it's consist with much
weaker hypotheses like a random energy
model or the much weaker hypotheses and
it actually looks a lot like this which
I flipped the axis around and it's
something from the late 90s and sort of
a very different type of strongly
correlated system right cause Fred said
it you know once you start to train an
engineer lots of correlations into
weight matrices what are the types of
strongly correlated systems that might
have analogous structural complexities
in how of a model and so this particular
one is from a protein folding paper in
the 90s we'll get back to that but just
as sort of planting and you know the
seed and the idea is in that area
there's a sort of a fairly rich wine and
work on what they call energy landscape
theory and so how you want to architect
the landscape in there and that's come
talked about a lot these days I think
with some level of confusion and so
we're gonna want to maybe shut some
clarity on that so the end what is the
energy landscape so if you think about
this as an optimization you write down
an optimization function you call a
black box so you call a white box
alternative you can say I'm just gonna
run some procedure and compute whatever
I compute and it's a bit of a sort of
mismatch between the two so in a lot of
in deep learning a lot of neural network
applications you have some sort of
optimization function that's some sort
of iterated thing and there's 500 of
those or whatever depending on how many
layers fred has and you want to train
this on data and so these things are
pretty data intensive but you minimize
some loss that depends on this relative
to the data so so the landscape in that
sense is the objective function of the
part of the objective function
parameterize by elements of weight
matrices inand bias vectors as defined
by the data so as you start feeding the
data through and propagating there is
back this changes right so the landscape
is changing at every up lock you may
write down this but this changes during
training and in fact part of training is
to architect this and so this is
changing at every and so when you say I
find no minima you're finding no minima
in the original landscape and the final
landscape or as you run along the
training process so this is the energy
landscape and people say well that's not
convex and so it must look like this so
how could it work and it's known in fact
for a long time that this is what it
looks like so
local minimums never a problem in
practice right now run your algorithm
stop don't say you're at a minimum ask
the question are you at a minimum and
look at the gradient look at the passing
the answer's no I mean maybe it close to
the minimum maybe the gradients large or
small but it empirically you're not at a
minimum the gradient is not zero to any
sort of numerical level of precision so
you just stop when you get tired or
maybe you stop according to some other
but it's not because you're at a minimum
here so this is obvious and it was
obvious back in the 90s so this is a
great book and you know low dimensional
faces local minimum are not a problem
you know saddle points in low dimension
spaces they might be a high dimensional
spaces local minima are not a problem
and you're not going to get stuck in
local minima
there's the saddle points there's a
range of other issues going on and so
what's happened in the last few years is
the fact what people do is to say I have
a model I just add gobs and gobs more
complexity so I can drive the training
error to zero and then you add you know
your regular eyes you over parameterize
and you regular eyes so what does it
mean to regularize so what is
regularization so regularization is one
of these things that I'm not going to
say what it is but I think that every
knob and switch in the training process
so it could be regulation knob it could
be batch size it could be learning rate
it could be time till you stop it could
be whether you pre-process the data this
way or that way or whether you clip
something to zero or whether use a
different random bit or whether you did
this or whether you did so every
adjustable knob and switches regulation
sort of emasculates it of its meaning I
think this paper has a taxonomy of 50
different methods so dropout early
stopping batch size adding noise so what
is regularization so the best paper
award given a couple years ago was given
to a paper that said if you add noise to
something that's like this you can you
can fit and you can't not you know you
can't not over fit so you actually wrote
something up that says you know
rethinking generalization just requires
revisiting old ideas going beyond sudden
BC theory and stuff that's been popular
recently that two ideas that were
well-known in terms of thinking about
load parameters at temperature
parameters which could be instantiated
from stochastic variant back size for
example this is the background what
we've been talking what we'll be talking
about so
basics of regulation so Ridge regression
we heard about this day and it's tick
ticking off Phillips softens the rank
you had a ridge term a lot of things are
like this you might tack on an l1 or an
l2 or something else there but but
you're sort of softening things out you
could do truncated SVD and an SVM is a
little like that right you just feed
basis vectors in and so that's a much
harder sort of truncation and so there's
a range of other things that do
something like this and so we want to do
is to say well you know there's a little
bit more complicated object if you were
to add regulation you're added on those
weight norms because this is like your
solution vector and so we're gonna not
ask the question it you know in a priori
sort of statement we want to ask in a
posterior statement and say what are
empirical signatures that we'd see all
right if I give you a least squares
problem and regularize it with an l1 and
l2 and l3 and I don't tell you which of
those it's going to be and I give you a
solution you give me a data I give you a
solution would you be able to tell me
which of those regular sized versions
I'd be using and maybe if you look at
how sparse or dense the output is you
could say yeah using a lasso or Ridge so
we're gonna study empirical properties
the solution vector to after the fact
answer the question as to what the
regularization looks like and so we're
going to characterize the implicit
regularization properties here by doing
exactly that so that's what I mean by an
A plus story or a theory that's gonna be
operational or predictive so we're going
to be characterizing the regularization
properties implicitly and you should
have the idea that the surface may look
something like that but you may never
see these bumps why because you have a
dozen knobs to fiddle with them so
you're gonna smooth those out so what
happens to the layer weight matrices W
so that's gonna be the key object that
we'll be talking about and if we're
gonna make empirical claims you know
what happens to the layer weight
matrices don't evaluate your method on
one or two or three out evaluations are
100 networks so we've evaluated a wide
range of networks hundreds of layers
what I'll talk about today is some very
simple things to illustrate some things
a three layer MLP a miniature version of
Alec's net we've trained it on Alex at
inception a wide range of other things
we can do it during training but we can
also apply it to the state-of-the-art
models go out there pull something down
ask what it looks like at a much final
level of granularity than how many
layers are there something like that
right look at fine scale signatures of
what's going on there so here's the sort
of stretch our muscles right so here's a
warm-up three layer MLP is
couple layers this is x-axis of epochs
training y-axis is entropy the entropy
of the eigenvectors so I computed a
bunch of eigenvectors are going to be
doing something spectral so gonna be
computing a bunch of eigenvectors and it
starts out at one it's a little bit
lower than one because of some
normalization but it starts at any one
then decreases decreases from point two
nine to I think two point nine one is
that a big change or not it depends so
you're here here in the first video it
was a bootcamp but someone remembers the
bootcamp it depends so we got to look at
this in a little bit more detail and the
stable rank the stable rank is a soft
version of the rank and that decreases
by a factor of two or something so this
is sort of suggestive and and but not in
you know not definitive people like to
look at scree plots and just cut
somewhere it you heard this morning me
who is cutting some or looking for you
know so you say your point eight is how
it starts and ends up at point fifteen
so you know a few are logon vectors that
are large but still goes down what does
this say does this say anything it
depends right so not at all clear what
that says so this is not a good lens to
view these things through so I'll answer
the question as to whether or not it
depends but by looking through a finer
scale lens look at them all look a whole
distribution we want the whole
distribution it's a bunch of vectors
computer generalized matrix entropy of
it yeah which is the matrix entropy
boils down to the eigen and then should
be on the eigenvectors yeah so we're
gonna be building up very simple things
like in vectors eigen values and just
being extremely precise and details
about them but like this is all we're
going to talk about the eigenvectors and
eigenvalues
okay so let's not look at this the scree
plot let's look at a histogram first of
all let's look at the eigen values and
the density or frequency that doesn't
say so much right it gets large and goes
down but if you look at the singular
value is the lens you should look at I
glossed over the aspect ratio of these
things in the interest of time but for
that the right thing to look at is in
fact the singular values and look at
that what is that called
that's called quarter-circle law and the
the red is before training and the blue
is almost exactly the same after
training except you put a little bump
there so the dip there correspond to
pulling out a spike
so we're looking at this through random
matrix theory which is with the quarter
circle is and going to make a finer
scale stamen so this is suggestive so
let's go into a little bit more detail
during training it starts out like this
this is not big enough semicircle I will
get to it in a minute but it's sort of a
rectangular version of that and as you
train the things become non-random and a
little bit of a spike pulls out it's at
three keep training keep training keep
training and it pulls up to about four
whatever
so we're inducing correlations and
structures so can we characterize what's
going on here so in fact the entropy
decreases corresponds to this
modification but before I looked at both
here we're gonna look at eigenvalues of
x2 Square and yeah but that's that's the
difference if you're schoolroom or not
but yeah yeah if you use random matrix
Theory it's one of a random matrices as
one is really a better way to look at it
than the other is this is the same plot
as we saw before it's a histogram of
eigenvalues x axis is the eigenvalue of
y-axis is the density the empirical
density and as you ne precedes the
subscribe pulled out so the dip in the
entropy was that I pulled this spike out
so is that significant not we'll get to
that but you know what you should be
thinking is if you are to train a what
you don't want to do because it's sort
of too simplistic but your training on
em nest or something and turn this crank
and you're going to get something like
this you could ask the question what if
I cut there and throw that out what do
you get so an M nest just to give you a
number you get 95% prediction accuracy
is that good or bad
bad it's a lot better than 10 so by
keeping the top say 10 of eicken vectors
out of 500 you get a lot of the way
there but of course to get 99.8 so
there's a lot of information here it's
just invisible to a very coarse lens so
there's information here if you cut that
off so there's a top there's a lot of
information everyone to understand
what's going to happen as you turn the
crank on that so the tool we're gonna
use is random matrix theory 101 is
something called bigness semicircle on
Tracy Widom Viktor says you know the
eigenvalues of a random matrix on a form
of semi circle there's various ways to
quantify that so the global bulk
statistics forms a nice shape and then
there's local deviations at the edge
that's Vigna this is not a Gaussian
distribution this is something
qualitatively different cuz there's
correlations there there's not
correlations there those are different
universality has its a qualitatively
different thing now these matrices are
not square or if they are square it's a
correlation matrix of this correlation
is very no really looking at something
art angular so we're not going to use
this but we're going to use the
rectangular version of this so the
rectangular version of this is something
called the Marchenko pressure
distribution this is it this is a
generalization of bigness semicircle to
rectangular matrices and in the same way
as you have that here's the shapes of it
on the top in the same ways you have the
bulk statistics and then fluctuations at
the edge we're going to be interesting
using random matrix theory to understand
the bulk statistics those shapes as well
as fluctuations at the edge what's going
on right there may be a spike pulls out
may be other funny stuff is going to
happen so that's we're gonna be asking
okay so we're gonna use this as a tool
to build a theory now it gets even more
complicated because that's only 102
we're going to look at 103
so the 99% use case in all of this is
random matrices we use Gaussian
distributions and by Gaussian
distributions I mean anything that looks
roughly like a Gaussian so the Gaussian
universality class and the lingo so fix
the mean fix the variance anything else
goes through right so if you look like
that you look like that up to log-log
terms and the usual stuff right you
could say what if I want a random matrix
where I don't have Gaussian entries I
could have entries that have bad
variance I don't have third moments so
as a limiting case I could ask about
heavy-tailed ran to make
theories of a random matrix element wise
heavy tail the power law where there's
an exponent it could be between 0 & 1
and these 1 & 2 in which case you may
have a mean or variance or may not could
be between 2 & 4 could be larger and
we're gonna get three qualitatively
different results so basic mp theory
which is a thing we saw before
you know nice Gaussian entries you're
gonna have the MP distribution it's
gonna be a relatively clean situation if
you have a bulk and a few spikes
sticking out that's roughly spiked
covariance model so you're gonna have a
similar sort of structure except a few
spikes sticking out and that's this is
very universal it's very robust as
there's a lot of Union you can change
the details of the entries and it's very
you know it's very robust if you have
heavy tail distribution say a power law
the properties between 2 & 4 between 0 &
2 2 & 4 & 4 & 6 are qualitatively
different to oversimplify sort of a
large story that I could talk more
detail offline about if it's larger than
4 you look MP in the limit but you may
have some finite size effects if you're
less than 4 you don't look MP in the
limit you have some other properties in
the limit finite size effects can be
large if you're less than 2 actually the
finite size effects are more mod modest
and so this is an important regime and
this is an important regime that were
going to be talking about all right so
we're gonna be using heavy tailed random
matrix theory now it's not obviously why
we'll get to that here's some there's a
lot of weed level details in terms of
fitting these parameters rights and I
thought I had the next one of these
slides I'm gonna gloss over or something
maybe I pulled the slide there's gonna
be a lot of technical details in terms
of actually getting the implementation
right it's nothing surprising but
there's not something you're gonna be
able to do in an afternoon
we have a nice get repo and so on so we
can follow up on that all right so we
looked at those are some toy problems
we're gonna look at a wide range of
other problems this is a subset if we
looked at four images a wide range of
architectures we've looked at a bunch of
other applications in data sets in
natural language and a range of things
and the leading order bit is it looks
like what I'll be talking about and then
there's more details that I can follow
up separately so let's look at Linette 5
so it's looking at 5 a state of the art
model or not that's what you asked this
question right if you ask this custom 25
years ago or 20 years ago the answer is
yes and what you see with Lynette 5 is
something like this which you can zoom
in looks like
that's a very good fit to the bulk plus
a few things that stick out so are these
densities random yes except some stuff
sticks out do you guys you test that
hypothesis the final where this is not
the final but the panel did the delay is
right before the final so what I'll be
talking about today we're looking at
fully connected layers when we can talk
offline about it other extensions were
looking at what you can do but it gets a
little bit more textured there but this
is the penultimate two layers before the
final layer that's net so is that well
described by the MP just by a random
matrix distribution or not that's the
full one zoom in remarkably not well not
as well certainly but even stronger
that's very not well so the shape is not
even right you'll lose a lot and you
have a lot of stuff bleeding out the
curvature the fluctuation of properties
are not a little dip but it bleeds out
very slowly if you look at this on a
log-log plot another shape that's clear
there's some heavy-tailed structure
going on here what the majority of
things look like this an exception is an
exception is Inception which has an
envelope like this but some other
structure going on in here suggesting
that maybe you could iterate someone
train that a little bit more so
motivated largely by alx net and Lynette
we wanted to put together a theory an
operational a phenomenological theory to
explain what's going on in terms of this
training process and the theories going
to use the bulk statistics and the edge
statistics the fluctuations on sistex at
the edge to characterize in a posteriori
way possible types of training possible
types of learned models and to give the
names I'll call them random like because
it's not random I could have a lot of
other informations buried in there but
it's consistent with random at the level
of a resolution that random matrix
theory looks at it it's random like a
little bit of bleeding out you see the
shape of that's very different than what
we saw in in in in the model a couple
slides ago
that's not bleeding out like that that's
pretty well described up to fluctuations
and then there's some sort of bump and
you can imagine that bumps of precursor
to something like this it's both plus
spikes
now keep training but this is not
necessary statement about the training
process I could maybe come up with these
this these these examples in other ways
you get a shape like this we get much
stronger decay the bulk starts to eat
away you get much stronger decay out
here and if you do that more this was
the best read fit we could find you just
get no good read fits and so call that
heavy-tailed
and you can again get a corner case you
just sort of lose hard rank not too soft
ring but hard rank alright so this is
what we'll call the five plus one phases
of learning for lack of a better term
and they correspond to think very
naturally to sort of a model you might
write down that your signal plus noise
the signal might be nothing it might be
a few spikes that stick out and the rest
is bulk but as you get irate this
training process what we want to say is
that the noise sort of gets eaten away
because we ate out that part of that
bulk and pulled more stuff out toward
spikes and so what's the signal the
signal is getting more and more strongly
correlated interactions engineered into
the training as a result of the training
process assuming your trainings are sort
of reasonable quality data and a not
obvious fact is that you can model
strongly correlated systems with random
matrices with heavy tail distributions
and so that's gonna be something that
we'll get to here so this is the
slightly more wordy description of the
picture pictorial description of five
plus one phase the training we saw
before there's a slide I thought we had
lots of technical issues so there's
still more lots of technical issues so
what's going on so the smaller older
models you should think of as a
perturbative approximation of some nice
limit you might want to prove theorems
about right gaussian random matrix
theory there's some perturbation you can
quantify it in different ways you get a
ball feet you get a bunch of spikes and
that is essentially ticking off type
regularization right there's a scale
ticking off says above this signal below
that's noise and there's some stuff
going on in between and and we saw that
that was the case for state of the art
models twenty years ago so what's going
on with realistic models now so every
realistic model now with the exception
of Inception which had that the funny
property looks exactly like this and
inception actually looks like a poorly
trained version of the following so
gonna model strongly correlated systems
by heavy-tailed random matrices in the
sense that the large-scale architecture
of the interaction space namely the
energy lane
scape could be modeled in that way and a
hello world way to describe that is in
terms of just the empirical spectral
distribution where you've eaten out a
part of this and you have a strong
bleeding out and you could have a few
spikes and you pull a few more things
out and a few more things out and
eventually you destroy that scale above
what your signal and below what your
noise and so this is a much a
qualitatively different type of
regularization than Ridge or any of a
range of other things that boil down to
Ridge like we have a F plus lambda G
where you can modulate this this is a
heavy tailed sort of self regularization
that so far as we know has never been
sort of pointed out here it has been
used a very different areas polymer
theory and some of the theory in that
table that I pointed you to that we've
lost over was Lu shard and part is that
they do statistical mechanics but apply
to quantitative finance and so a lot of
the technical issues we're talking about
here arose there and or dealt with there
so what we suspect today is you know
state of the art train models is no
single threshold there's no nice
low-rank approximation there are the
modes there are most important
directions it's ten or twenty or thirty
of them however many most important
directions you want but it's not even
like this where you get most of the
information they just capture very
little of the strong correlations and as
you include more and more eigenvectors
you think you more and more on a heavy
tailed way and they can't be treated
perturbatively and so asking for a
priority sort of formulations of theory
is not at all obvious that you can do
this getting a posteriori estimates of
the sort we're talking about is probably
a much more productive way to do that
but in case they're not a perturbative
approximation of some nice limit states
and we've seen that as I said instead of
every quote every sort of thing we've
looked at you can look at localized
eigenvectors you can look at what
happens if you exogenous lis ad
regulation what if you noise if I date
or what if you would if you would have
you and it's consistent with sort of the
story I sort of laid out so initiative
time let not me let me not go into those
sort of issues but let me talk about one
particular example about burying the
batch size optimization procedure using
so I can certainly come up with an
optimization procedure that changes this
and damages everything in terms of
prediction quality so the claim is a
claim about the world it's not a claim
about optimization procedures there's a
phenomenon the world that there's people
out there that do this and they train
certain things and we're going out
binoculars looking at the jungle and
seeing what people do and formulating a
theory based on that and so based on
that if you look at state-of-the-art
stuff that's done the leading order bit
is that all looks like that there's a
few exceptions that sort of prove the
rule the inception one there's a few
other things
NLP convolutional let's talk offline but
but yeah and so what if you are just
learning rate and compensate for that
what Beck's eyes are just this and
compensate for that yeah follow-up work
but the expectation is that the
correlational structure that you
engineer into the learn model regardless
of that would exhibit something like
this this strong correlations over many
size scales which is what you see in
other sort of physical systems and in
localization on IgAN I mean all these
metrics become more so if you add
exogenous regulation you had noise to
data etc so so let me skip over that in
the interest of this time and let me
talk about one particular regularization
parameter which is the batch size of
course it's not a regulation parameter
to back size but yeah
right yeah I started this essentially
it's that lambda scheme is very flat and
it's very nice because of this is cheap
connection so yeah so there's a we're
looking at the energy of a single layer
we haven't asked the question across
layers for fully connected layers so far
but we have some results that I'm not
going to talk about here I think there's
two things one is what's the shape of
the local interaction and it's not clear
to me that that matters so much in a lot
of ways because you have so many of the
knobs it will damage that local shape
more important is how would maybe layers
interact or something and that's
something that's heavily engineered
based on I mean you work with an
architecture that's good for images is
not going to work for natural languages
on this that's heavily engineered so so
I don't know the answer but we could
conjecture some things offline if you
wanted yeah
so we have a theory we we saw a bunch of
results on the Linette now it's done a
few other things we posited that this 5
plus this degenerate 1 phase of training
is this talk yeah can we exhibit the
phases you know can we use it to
understand better anything right a sign
of control
is if you can vary a knob or 2 or 3 or
10 or 20 but if you can vary a knob and
say exhibit all five of these phases
it's a sign of sort of scientific
control in the sense that I've buried
these things now it's complimentary
thing is I want to exhibit engineering
control I want engineer a system that's
robust against these things and so what
a lot of people say is well I just want
a better system and so I just want to
always be state-of-the-art
and so let's take a step back that's a
scientific question and follow-up work
is you know engineer better you know
interfaces to an architecture or
something so for right now let's ask the
question to say can we exhibit all of
those phases by changing one knob and
you already saw that we could exhibit
several of the phages right one when I
showed you the MLP three we exhibit
random like we exhibit random plus a
spike as we trained so can we exhibit
these other ones that I'm drawing from
heavy-tailed random matrices so let's
vary the batch size and so we should be
able to make predictions we set a bunch
of phase to do they exist there's many
many knobs that are going to vary one
and let's turn it from large to small
this is particularly interesting because
in the same ways VC Theory provides
feedings mismatched to what people do in
practice convex stochastic optimization
theory says this and you look at the day
you know the result and it says
something qualitatively different and so
we want to you know vary the back side
from large to small and see if we can
understand what's going on there
here we're gonna take a small trainable
retrain of a model which we did in some
cases that this is the miniature version
of Alex net four bunch of those things
we looked out of the world at large
pre-trained things which is something I
think that sort of undervalued in this
area people everyone wants to train
their own but just glass but what if
this data look like out there here we're
gonna take a small version of me on that
retrain it and exhibit all the phases if
you don't know this what it's what's
seen is that convex sort of stochastic
optimization suggests that larger
batches are better you get a lower
variance on your gradient estimate and
so it's more like a deterministic
optimization and what people have seen
is just qualitatively different
properties in terms of these sort of
problems that you get poorer
generalization properties if you get
larger batches so that's oversimplifying
sort of a textured story but so large
batch sizes lead to some sort of
decrease in generalization accuracy and
so can we characterize this in terms of
implicit regularization alright because
if you pull spikes out in the bulk plus
spike and as we pulled spikes out and
get this heavy tailed property that's de
facto I mean that that is a after the
fact characterization of implicit
regulation on the late matrices so
almost equals small back sizes lead to
better models that's that's the claim
this is batch size small to large batch
size small to large stable ranked empty
soft rank which is a notion of where the
cut from the best MP fit relative to the
largest eigenvalue is both will decrease
their different metrics but they
correlate pretty strongly
similarly here those are two different
layers on alex net accuracy down is good
because we're plotting one over accuracy
ask wait a while tell you so decreasing
batch sizes lead to better results
decreasing batch sizes will induces
strong correlations right the stable
rank is decreasing increasing backsides
lead to worse results it's washing out
these correlations and so as you change
batch size 500 you look random like 250
you're starting to eat out a little bit
there but you're still sort of random
like hundred you start to see a bit of a
jump out here right 32 your ball plus
spikes how greedy can you get 32 hours
telling people a few weeks ago get
greedy go down to 16 or 816 the spikes
pull out and you're getting a bit of
this bleeding out of the bulk keep going
to 8 more of this more of this and
you're eating away this go down to 4
more of this more of this go down to 2
you can't even get a good fit no I'm no
good MP fit so by changing just the
batch size parameter we're able to get
all 5 through all 5 here you can tack on
an extra thing and get the degenerate
case so all the main phases of laning
that we posited can you do it with
learning rate and this and that I'm sure
the answer is yes so follow forth but
this is a particularly of seeing
parameter because it's not typically
thought of as a regulation parameter so
decreasing batch sizes in is inducing
strong correlations and W leading to a
more implicitly regularized model so
this is an explanation for why that
works you're implicitly constructing a
more regular eyes model how do we know
it we've defined regulation to be things
that are regular eyes things that have
all the empirical signatures of
regularization so is this the time for
the show is over so let me skip lots of
details in terms of how to apply the
theory and lots of other goodies and
I'll wrap up small things you know these
things the training process induces
regularization right I mean define if
like a duck and talks like a duck it is
a duck right it has all the empirical
signatures of regulation some of which
I've described those are old ones modern
ones have this heavy-tailed
self-organization which is a much more
substantial and significant thing
because it washes out that size scale
and this is correlations over many many
size scales we're modeling strongly
correlated signals with heavy-tailed
random matrices so we're stealing a page
from polymer theory and and doing that
and we're using the global bulk
statistics and local entity stiix of
random matrix theory we're looking
beyond sort of where randomized linear
algebra works to the fault lines where
it doesn't and poking down very hard on
that to explain the generalization gap
and the slides I glossed over at the end
tells you why the landscape is ruggedly
convex the energy landscape is
relatively convex so I think there's
goodies outside if if you want to hear
why it's ruggedly convex
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so you're looking at the covariance of
weight matrices what would it be if you
looked at the covariance of the
activation matrices with respect to a
data set so we have some results I don't
much more limited so why do we talk
offline because we have a few results
but it's not I don't know the answer so
good question we did look at a specific
data set and then we looked at 99 others
so the data sets we looked at were from
a wide range of domains including vision
and images and a wide range of
architecture so we only looked at 99 or
100 specific data sets so it's possible
this the next one we look at will be
different now we do know that if we land
and I say that not to tease I mean we
look at a new one you see something
different some of the new ones that
we've looked at are a little bit
different some are exactly sort of
essentially the same there's a lot of
knobs people use had we developed this
theory 20 years ago we would have looked
at it and you wouldn't have seen results
to support our predictions why because
the you know the net 5 and those things
back then I mean when you apply it to M
and s they're too small to see any of
this stuff so you're really need to get
to a scale so I don't wanna make a claim
about the world that this is gonna solve
all the world's problems right maybe in
some number of years something will come
up with something fancy that violates
this is this what this is supposed to be
is a theory to explain what's going on
so we go and look at you know dozens of
data sets hundreds of layers and this
explains it in terms of the properties
of the knobs I think if you look at what
we put up last year and you say what are
the structural parameters the structural
properties of the data of the learning
method of whatever the describe
qualitative what's going on you know
some combinatorial like B thing like VC
dimensions just a
I mean there's no evidence to suggest
that that's going to make qualitative
predictions go back and look at you know
load like parameters which lower load
captures something about the amount of
data that you're forcing through the
network which you know if you noise if I
the data it's very plausible that you're
changing the load I don't know of a
precise formulation that but it's very
plausible you're changing the load and
your variance or temperature like
parameters and so yup some sort of phase
space and the iteration process iterates
you to some some corner that's and not
quite at the spin glass phase but almost
so this is a structural theory that's
making a prediction and you know the
claim isn't I mean I think the question
is what would when I say why does it
work you know why you know why are we in
this room yeah there's a lot of ways to
answer that right so what would make you
happy in terms of the answer to why
what's and not we're here because it's
early in lately I mean the form of the
answer right some people would only be
happy if I can formulate it in in a way
that reduces to some combinatorial thing
and I can make some people's NP claim so
that's I'm not doing that
some people would be happy if I can go
out and make predictions and exhibit all
the phases and explain sort of
qualitatively why the generalization gap
works because smaller batch sizes you're
capturing fine scale correlation so we
tried to take a scientific tactic here
to make a based on data based on random
matrix Theory formulate a theory I
described it visually in terms of what's
going on that would make very particular
predictions and the particular
predictions were that if you look at
this you can exhibit different phases as
you change knobs you know etc so you
know you may have a different data set
that's different so we made a prediction
and test us out and prove us right or
wrong I mean we did try and formulate
the question in a way that's falsifiable
so prove me wrong I'll be very happy if
you prove me wrong I think a lot of
theoretical statements are not
formulated in a way that could be proven
right or wrong so prove me right or
prove me wrong so what I'd say
[Applause]